الأجانب
لا ينامون أبدًا في هذا الطابق من
المطار ، هناك دائمًا خيارات
يحق لي استرداد أموالي بالكامل ، ولكن
تم إلغاء هذه الرحلة بسبب سوء
الأحوال الجوية ، فليس خطأنا
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، الحقيقة هي معظم الأشياء
التي  يحق لي التقديم فقط إذا
لم يكن الأمر متعلقًا بالطقس ، لذلك بالنسبة
للتأخيرات المتعلقة بالطقس ، فإن أول شيء
سأفعله هو التحقق من بطاقتك الائتمانية التي
اشتريت منها الرحلة مع العثور على
مزايا بطاقة الائتمان ومعرفة ما
إذا كان هناك شيء يشير إلى
تأخير السفر  الحماية أو التأمين على تأخير السفر
مسؤول عن القليل جدًا عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالتأخيرات أو الإلغاءات المتعلقة بالطقس ،
والاستثناء الوحيد لذلك
هو إذا ألغوا رحلتك بسبب
الطقس ، يحق لك استرداد المبلغ بالكامل
بغض النظر عما إذا قررت عدم
السفر
من أجل  أنه يتعين عليك من الناحية الفنية الانتظار
حتى يتم إلغاء الرحلة فعليًا ،
لكن ما رأيناه الكثير من شركات الطيران تفعله
الآن هو عندما يتوقعون
طقسًا سيئًا ، فإنهم يمنحونك خيار
تغيير رحلتك إلى وقت لاحق لذلك
يبدو أن هناك  المزيد من المرونة التي
تسمح بها شركات الطيران ،
وبالمناسبة ، إذا لم تعجبك
الرحلة التي أعادوا حجزها لك بعد خمسة
أيام من الآن ، فيجب عليك الاتصال وطلب
رحلة مبكرة أو السؤال عما إذا كان
لديهم شركة طيران شريكة يمكنهم الحصول
عليها  في رحلة سابقة ،
وأفضل شيء تفعله خاصةً عندما
يتعلق الأمر بتأخيرات الطقس الآن هو الدردشة
عبر الإنترنت إذا استطعت لأن لا أحد يرغب في
البقاء على الهاتف لمدة خمس ساعات ، لذا إذا
كان هناك خيار للدردشة عبر الإنترنت مع
ممثلي شركة الطيران ،  يجب أن
أفعل ذلك تمامًا ، أقول دائمًا إذا
لم تطلب منك ألا تحصل على ذلك حتى إذا
لم يكن لك الحق بالضرورة في
غرفة في فندق أو وجبة بسبب التأخير
بسبب الطقس ، فلا يزال يتعين عليك طلب
ذلك ومن الواضح أن  لطيف جدًا عندما
تسأل فريد ولكن شركات الطيران تريد الاحتفاظ
بك كعميل ، لذا سيبذلون
قصارى جهدهم لاستيعابك حتى لو لم يكن ذلك مضمونًا ، فمن الأفضل أن
تسأل بدلاً من
مجرد افتراض أنهم لا يستطيعون مساعدتك